I'm deliberately reviewing and moving
away from Susan sequences because you're
starting a new topic today though it's a
continuation of old stuff you might be
able to guess from the review questions
let's start with the tough one one a we
should all be able to do this derivative
it's 2x thank you
this negative 4 is just kind of like a
distractor right what difference that
negative 4 make to the gradient answer
nothing it changes your position up and
down just doesn't change whether you're
whether you're steep or whether you're
shadow all about Part B some people ask
me some questions about this there's a
rule that we can use to make this easy
what's the name of the rule chain rule
right because if I didn't use the chain
rule I have to take that power of seven
and I have to expand that whole thing
and that would just take forever in fact
it's exactly why I gave you the number
seven rather than like the number two or
three because you probably could expand
it that what I wanted you to see I don't
want you to expand this you can do it
without how do I get the derivative
don't give me the answer give me some
steps okay so we do often think of the
numbers moving around but I'm gonna ask
you again even though it's correct
what's the operation that I do what's
the name of that I'm gonna multiply by
seven that's the power right okay so I'm
gonna write the rest of it which you
kind of are implying but having said and
then yeah that power reduces by one
that's a six now most people got to this
point that some of us forgot the chain
rule we've differentiated the outside
part which is something to the power of
7 then you've got to do the inside part
which is 2 there's there's that inside
derivative right there too
so that's how you get the 14 are you
happy with that is that all right yep
okay Part C I did give you a bit of a
nudge with this one it's a fraction and
it's not one that can be easily written
in some other form so we can't avoid the
fact that it's a fraction the name of
the rule is question rule thank you so
you need to know which ones which you've
got a numerator here which I'm going to
call you and a denominator which I'm
going to call V and then you can launch
in to the question rule hopefully this
is something which I know it's kicking
around in the cobwebs up there it's been
a while but let's just and that's it
together what's the first thing I'm
gonna write at the top
it's just if the X plus one to be you -
in this case you - is three then I do a
- that's tricky because that's different
to the product rule and then I go again
but I say instead of vu - I'm gonna do
UV - right so here comes you 3x - 5 V -
in this case is it's one which doesn't
change things but I like to write that
it's one anyway because for me number
one it's a mental check that I've got
the whole rule there number two it
communicates to the person reading my
working I I knew where this came from
and it's not like it just disappears
it is there what's on this denominator V
squared which in this case is X plus 1
or square which I know you can expand as
x squared plus 2x plus 1 do you think it
matters not not usually
okay can we tidy up this top part here
3x + 3 I can't I really got to be
careful here without negatives right
then the negatives is one of the
trickiest things about the question rule
there's a double negative here so I'm
gonna go minus 3x plus 5 very good and
that's still an X plus 1 all squared
leaving me with knew right off
yeah just eight because these three X's
will cancel each other out and I am
doing this skis there we are happy all
right now if I had all the quick look
around and saw some of your graphs for
sine X I'm just gonna I've got enough
space just to do a really sneaky small
one down here I asked you to do it from
naught to 2pi which tells you what are
the units of my angles in there radians
right if I were if I provided you not to
360 degrees you'd know the other way and
this is roughly what I'm hoping to see
ok well that sort of was a bit bad be in
there you're gonna have I've asked you
to put intercepts on how many other
there's one here which is the obvious
one but then there's also the ones on
the ends right so I've got zero over
here I've got more be careful I'm gonna
put plant in a second but this is not
pile on - what's this
this is halfway right so it's ply last
one two pi are you happy with that
amount information well ieave strictly
speaking you've done all the things I
asked you to do but what other things
are important that might be helpful okay
so these guys up here they're not
intercepts because I'm not colliding
there but yeah what's this called start
with r this is the range right negative
one to one and that sort of maps across
to here play on - I'm pretty happy with
that I just asked you for the basics
okay yeah exactly
replant - is the other station report
defender